the critical ideologies that uh
have been mainstreamed in university
these are then carried into not just
gov government by people who then end up
being
advisors and staff who work on campaigns
and people who get elected to city
government
become leaders and police departments
probably the most important thing is
that that ideology then takes root
completely in journalism
and this was literally what many of us
were talking about for years saying you
know if you label
everyone nazis and then you say it's
okay to punch a nazi well you've given
yourself the excuse to
to basically not only physically attack
people but burn down buildings
and everything else um what do you make
of all of the
people and we we heard this a lot i mean
i heard this a lot from my own people
oh dave this is just a college campus
thing
this won't leak out into reality um
clearly they were not correct
um i wish they were right but um
we've seen i mean the
the critical ideologies that uh have
been mainstreamed in university
these are then carried into not just
gov government by people who then end up
being
advisors and staff who work on campaigns
and people who get elected to city
government
um become leaders and police departments
probably the most important thing is
that that ideology then takes root
completely in journalism so if you look
in the mainstream press
you can see what's particularly happened
at
like america's paper of raqqa the new
york times
or the washington post and you just see
um
how um it's a
hard left political monoculture that is
extremely intolerant
and has provided so much legitimacy to
far-left extremism i mean it's these
papers who have published
these really culturally significant
opinion pieces
in news reports as well that are
sympathetic or provide a justification
for property destruction looting and all
that in the name of
social justice um online news
news sites and magazines are no better
they also
argue for the need for
violent protests so um
they're undoing a lot of what were
norms in uh are in the united states
and i think this is where antifa has had
the most success
not in necessarily their acts of
violence and destruction
which they have done so much created so
much misery from that
but actually that tenets of the ideology
have found
footing in the mainstream left and have
been giving a certain
legitimacy in society and the other
thing people have to realize is that
um for those who sympathize with
uh when i talk to people who are
supportive of sympathizing with
the capitol hill uh siege right on the
6th of january
um their response was often well for
months and months
yeah the alum and antiques are got to
riot and
respond to their grievances with
violence and that was cheered on and
nothing happened to them so
why do we have to be peaceful so this is
the the danger as well that it creates
antifa's extremism creates
reactions on the right and the far right
that can lead to a lot of violence and
we've already seen a lot in 2020 and i
don't think it's slowing down this year
yeah do you sense that that double
standard where
when the lefties you know burn down
buildings and attack private property
and stop
cars in the street and make people you
know denounce white supremacism and the
litany of other things happen
do you think the the double standard
from the way the media covers that
to the way they covered the capital
obviously without excusing any of the
violence of the capital
that that really is is just
completely burst forth like to me at
this point cnn is not a place of
journalism the new york times
is not a place of journalism like are
you willing to go that far on that
well what made me furious in seeing the
condemnations from
journalists influential thinkers
politicians in response to the riot on
the 6th of january is
i wonder why they were at best silent
when my city
was under siege one federal property in
portland yeah
when what those rioters did on the six
they did that in worst
last year okay why were they silent then
at best and then at work some of them
actually were promoting
these crowdfunding campaigns to get some
of these accused
riot suspects back on the streets right
so quite literally i mean there were
hollywood celebrities and and quote
unquote journalists
putting money in and crowdfunding to get
rioters that had done violent acts
illegal acts to get them out of jail not
that they would have really been
prosecuted in portland or seattle anyway
uh however i'm fairly certain if uh
you know anyone on the right if if glenn
beck or ben shapiro had done a gofundme
to get some of the
january six people even if they hadn't
been violent out of jail
i think it might have been taken a
little differently are you
shocked how quickly the liberals have
just folded
on this thing you you know my feelings
on this sort of that this
is what we've seen antifa do to the left
is sort of the it's the death end
of liberalism sort of and i've watched
so many of my friends just not be able
to understand that are you shocked that
liberals seem to have no defense
mechanism
against this uh i'm not shocked anymore
given
what's happened in the past five years i
mean
when people who
when liberals uh systematically failed
to
really defend um what
the academy should be about that was the
first line right if they're not willing
to defend
freedom of expression of speech in
academic institutions
i uh i don't think they would defend it
outside of that so
i'm not shocked but i think
the reason why i've become really
powerful is because they do
have many many synthesizers and
supporters
on the mainstream left people who don't
understand
or don't know antifa's violence
extremist audiology who really think
that these are
just merely people who are anti-cashless
who
are going out to protect people of color
on the street from neo-nazis
i think um and it's a welfare ignorance
because
um i mean yes a lot of the media has
been so
reckless in their coverage of antifa but
there's also been some good coverage
and um you know my work has been printed
in
mainstream publications and all that um
but it's just i mean this the rule
that's been laid out is essentially you
can do
anything and everything including kill
for the
alleged cause of racial justice and
social justice
so when you lay that out as
like the contacts for all these things
to happen
there's no ability for the left to
really be able to counter
you know and it should be pretty easy
but you know antifa people think that if
you're against
them that means you're pro far if you're
against blm i think people
will accuse you of being against black
americans
instead of diving into looking at what
these movements actually espouse and
what they do have you been able to break
down
some of the numbers on this like like
how many of them actually
are there how many of them are taking
place you know
actually taking part in the violent
attacks versus i think a lot of the
people when i see like their sort of
allies
in the media like i would look at
somebody like jake tapper i don't think
he's like a promoter
of antifa i wish he i think he probably
wishes they didn't exist
but he's the type of guy that just won't
really tweet when they're burning down a
city but if the right wing does you know
anyone on the right does anything
it's insurrection so have you been able
to figure out just like how many foot
soldiers there are
versus how many just sort of self
hostages in the media who just don't
want to get attacked
you know just sort of a general
breakdown of the amorphous
thing um so exact numbers
across the u.s would be i think
impossible
to calculate just because there's no in
terms of
a lot of these antifa organizations we
have actually no
idea how many people are involved uh in
my
book i look specifically because i got
leaked
public uh documents internally from rose
city antifa which is importantly
for organization the largest one in the
u.s so i can give
estimates for let's say portland because
we just we have so many
um data points of how many
of the recurring nightly rights how many
people come
and for that it can range anywhere from
as little as 50 people
to thousands i noticed consistently
though the number of people who are
actually donning
their black uniforms which is part of
the black bloc
tactics um and those who are committing
that to violence
that numbers really even at its
peak no more than a couple hundred
so if there was a political will
and that's the the important word is
political will
to um stop this
wanton extremism and violence and
destruction
it can be done easily however
the mayor um really actually
continuously was giving sort of
um excuses for them saying like oh i
understand that we're pro
you're protesting against racial
injustice and systemic racism
and just anytime you buy into that
narrative you're giving legitimacy to
their cause
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell